now steve bannon says he'll appeal his
guilty verdict the former campaign
strategist and adviser to former u.s
president donald trump was convicted on
two counts of criminal contempt for
defying subpoenas from the committee
investigating last year's insurrection
at the u.s capitol
thank you i want to thank start by
thanking the jury
we respect their decision today steve
bannon was defiant in his remarks to
reporters following his conviction in
u.s federal court immediately indicating
he plans to appeal the ruling
we may have lost the battle here today
but we're not going to lose this war
this employee told us the u.s committee
investigating the january 6th
insurrection at the u.s capitol asked
bannon to provide documents and testify
in person about efforts to overturn the
2020 election bannon ignored both
subpoenas so the case was referred to
the justice department however the
committee did obtain leaked audio of
bannon discussing the president's
strategy to declare victory no matter
what and aired it at a public hearing
this week let's listen
and what trump's going to do is just
declare victory right he's going to
declare a victory
but that doesn't mean he's the winner
he's just going to say someone the
democrats
more of our people vote
early that count theirs voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and trump's going to take
advantage of that's our strategy this is
going to clear us up winner so when you
wake up wednesday morning
it's going to be a firestorm
and of course four days later president
trump declared victory when his own
campaign advisors told him he had
absolutely no basis to do
so is a left wing
although bannon only lasted seven months
in the white house after helping trump
win in 2016 he was brought back in after
the 2020 election to help devise a
strategy to keep trump in office
one last thing i stand with trump and
the constitution thank you very much
[Applause]
bannon remains free pending his
sentencing scheduled for october the
21st
and for more on this let's bring in dw
correspondent mikaela kufna in
washington d.c
let's start with the latest steve bannon
once a key ally to trump now faces jail
time he didn't testify in his defense or
call any witnesses so not a huge
surprise he was found guilty is it
that's not a huge surprise clearly he
refused to even hand over any documents
but you can't simply get away
with not cooperating in the face of a
house committee
but his lawyer has already said that
they will appeal he says he has
bulletproof
information that will prevent steve
bannon from going to prison it could be
up to two years so this is still um open
once again but a very clear indicator
there that he can't simply wiggle out of
this
returning to the january 6 hearing the
attorney general has emphasized that no
one is above the law so why is it so
difficult to build a case against donald
trump
well anyone who was watching those three
hours last night here in washington dc
clearly could detect a case anyone who
still cares
about facts and merrick garland made
that statement
two days before
this and indicating that even a
president will not be above the law a
former president not a sitting president
and now all eyes are
on the attorney general general garland
of what he will do with this information
he has said that he doesn't want to talk
about
anything in the open
but clearly a president saying he
doesn't want to say that the elections
are over when they are over that is
hardly something that can be ignored
but one thing is for sure the
implications the political waves and the
public reaction amongst trump followers
would follow immediately
so we expect some kind of a statement
from there very soon
beyond producing evidence for the
department of justice
this
is also an event made for the american
public it was on primetime tv yesterday
how effective have the hearings been in
creating awareness about trump's role in
the insurrection
well it is splashed all over the media
there are phone-ins there are programs
everywhere but the big question mark is
really are those people who
already who now saw evidence what they
already believed had happened that
donald trump did absolutely nothing and
there were clear indicators beforehand
for that
those who stick with trump simply do not
care that is the sense one clearly gets
here
whether there is evidence footage
showing him saying that he doesn't want
to say anything in the direction that he
doesn't want to admit that it's over and
that
he simply said that mike pence let him
down that's his own vice president so
interestingly the former vice president
and him are also
supporting different candidates here in
primaries in a race for instance
um but will these facts get through i
think that is the overarching problem
with
u.s politics but also with the upcoming
campaign for the midterms in november
pw's michaela couffner joining us from
washington dc thank you so much
you